Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Ich bin eigentlich immer wieder überrascht, dass wir es dann auch immer schaffen, einen Morgentermin zu machen. Ich meine, das glaubt uns ja am Ende keiner, dass wir uns wirklich auch immer morgens treffen.
Und du nährst jetzt das Gerücht?
Na, das steht glaube ich eh im Raum, oder? Das fragt sich jeder.
Wann wir das überhaupt machen?
Es ist alles wahr. Überhaupt wie wir es hier ohnehin nur mit der Wahrheit halten und nichts als der Wahrheit, so sie uns sich darstellt. So würde ich das mal umreißen. So, dieses Mal sitzen wir nicht in einem Studio, sondern sind ein wenig räumlich getrennt. Aber das macht ja überhaupt nichts, denn wir haben ja das Internet, noch haben wir es. Und die Themen stehen fest. Womit fangen wir denn an?
Ja, mit jemandem, der auch die reine Wahrheit und nichts als die Wahrheit gesagt hat. Großer Aufreger in der letzten Woche, Sven Regener, findet Raubkopierer Scheiße. Das hat er in einem Radio-Interview gesagt bei BR Zündfunk. Und jetzt ist es ja so, Sven Regener ist wahrscheinlich allen bekannt als Frontmann von Element of Crime und Autor der grandiosen Bücher, Herr Lehmann, Neue Far Süd, der kleine Bruder. Also denke ich, einer der großen deutschen Kulturschaffenden. Und der hat in einem Radio-Interview, wo der irgendwie zum Urheberrecht befragt und sagte, ja, die Plattformen ermöglichen es ihnen, ihnen irgendwie Musik zu machen. Und er ärgert sich darüber, dass wenn man sagt, man ist fürs Urheberrecht, dann ist man heutzutage uncool. Und wer sagt, man wolle seine Leistungen oder seine Ergebnisse einfach so haben und damit seien sie wertlos, der würde ihm ins Gesicht pinkeln. Das wäre eine Frage von Respekt und Anstand. Im Supermarkt klaut man auch nichts und die Indie-Labels sind schon alle tot. Es gibt nur Fox-Musik-Schlager und Pop. Ja, und dann kam er irgendwann zu dem Kern der Angelegenheit, die ihn wohl großartig ärgert. Das ist wohl Google in Form von YouTube in diesem Streit mit der GEMA. Wir wissen das, ich weiß gar nicht, seit wie vielen Jahren das jetzt ist, wenn man ein Musikvideo mit GEMA-geschützten Inhalten oder GEMA-registrierten Inhalten auf YouTube sehen will, dann sind die Chancen groß, dass das nicht zu sehen ist. Und da steht dann, dieser Inhalt ist in deinem Land wegen der GEMA nicht verfügbar.
Ja, mittlerweile auch ein großer Renner auf Demonstrationen.
Genau, und daran, dass es ein großer Renner ist, sieht man schon, dass das sehr viele Leute ärgert. Und der Hintergrund dieser Angelegenheit ist also, dass YouTube für jede Ausstrahlung, also pro Klick dieses Videos, irgendwie an die GEMA einen Betrag leisten muss bzw. soll.
Und auch bereit ist, das zu tun, weil das ist ja meines Wissens auch die Regelung mit vielen anderen Anbietern.
Genau, YouTube ist bereit, das zu tun, allerdings nicht in dem Ausmaße oder nicht in den Betrag, den die GEMA gerne hätte.
Hast du da eigentlich mal jemals was gehört, um was für Beträge da tatsächlich gefeilscht wird?
Ich hab das tatsächlich mal gehört auf einer Konferenz im Rahmen der Berlin Music Week bei der A2N und ich kann die genauen Preise jetzt nicht mehr wiedergeben. Ich weiß nur, dass es, also natürlich sind das Cent-Beträge oder Untercent-Beträge, trotzdem streiten die sich da um so einen Faktor, der irgendwie zweistellig ist, mindestens. Also die sind mit ihren, quasi die GEMA ist mit ihren Forderungen in einem, also sehr viel höher prozentual gesehen, als YouTube irgendwie Bereitschaft signalisiert.
Da drängt sich so ein bisschen die Vermutung auf, dass die GEMA sich da mit ihren Forderungen noch in einem anderen Jahrzehnt befindet. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob diese Vermutung richtig ist.
Es ist vor allem die Frage, also ich, wenn Regener spricht, das in seinem Video auch schon in seinem Radiorant dann auch so an und sagt, ja, wenn es das bei YouTube nicht gibt, dann guckst halt woanders. Wir haben es ja auf elementofcrime.de. Das finde ich eigentlich sogar begrüßenswert. Einmal ein bisschen dezentralisieren und natürlich kann ich verstehen, dass die Haltung von YouTube, sich darum zu bemühen, möglichst die Inhalte kostenlos zu bekommen, da vielleicht auf ein bisschen Widerspruch stößt. Aber ich denke vor allem, weil er so aufgeregt ist, weil er auch sieht, ja klar, alle meckern irgendwie, weil seine Musik nicht auf YouTube ist, weil da gucken sie es halt nun mal. Und wenn er nicht da ist, dann gucken die Leute sich halt andere Sachen an. Da sind wir natürlich in so einem Spannungsfeld, dass da jetzt einfach andere Player so ein bisschen völlig überraschend oder unerwartet da so eine Art Macht- und Marktposition, Markt-Macht-Position, entwickelt haben, ja insbesondere YouTube. Auf jeden Fall muss man natürlich auch sagen, dass YouTube diese Sache natürlich sehr gut spielt. Also sagen wir mal, die streiten sich da um ein paar Prozente. Aber YouTube spielt die Angelegenheit natürlich sehr elegant, indem sie da diese Sperrungen drauf machen. Jeder, der das sieht, riecht sich auf über die GEMA, niemand über YouTube. Das Ding hat es inzwischen zum Mem gebracht, dass auf Demonstrationen irgendwie repliziert wird. Und die GEMA hat für einen größeren Teil der Öffentlichkeit, die das betrachtet, die Arschkarte. Dabei will sie doch nur Geld für die Künstler haben. Was ja sogar stimmt. Die GEMA ist ja wirklich im Prinzip was ganz Positives für die Künstler. Von den Labels werden sie ja ohnehin relativ kurz gehalten. Das war die andere Gruppe, für die der Regener da eine Lanze bricht. Da ist ihm dann auch relativ viel geschriebener Kritik oder Berichtigung entgegengeflogen. Wo dann eben gesagt wird, ja schau mal, ihr habt doch jetzt ganz andere Verwertungsmöglichkeiten für eure Kunst und die Plattenfirmen. Also ich mein, man muss ja überlegen, wie funktioniert eine Plattenfirma? Eine Plattenfirma ist eigentlich sowas wie Promotion Agentur und Bank in einem. Die geben irgendwie Kredite für die Künstler, um überhaupt deren Musik irgendwie groß rauszubringen. Achso und Vertrieb natürlich, Vertriebsstruktur auch noch. Die geben denen irgendwie ein Kredit, finanzieren dieses Album vor, malen die auf tausend Plakate, sehen zu, dass die irgendwie auf den Radiosendern häufig gespielt werden und sehen zu, dass irgendwie Stars, Marken etabliert werden und gekauft werden. Und das lassen sie sich natürlich sehr gut bezahlen. Und gleichzeitig haben sie so eine Art Gatekeeper-Funktion, die sie jetzt gerade so ein bisschen dadurch verlieren, dass es immer mehr Bands gibt, die sagen, ja, wir brechen aus diesem Zyklus aus, entweder zum Zeitpunkt, wo wir schon bekannt sind. Hier Trent Rezner mit Nine Inch Nails hat das ja gemacht. Radiohead hat ja auch mal so Versuche in die Richtung gestartet. Oder eben natürlich auch eine ganze Menge Musiker, die so anfangen auf Soundcloud und dann auf einmal ihre Fan-Basis haben.
Und die auch von daher von einem ganz anderen Anteil an den realen Umsätzen der verkauften Musik profitieren, wenn sie das selber in die Hand nehmen. Das selber in die Hand zu nehmen war bisher natürlich kaum vorstellbar, aber online oder auf Konzerten ist halt eine ganze Menge mehr möglich.
Und da denke ich, in diesen vier Minuten oder was die er da rumschreibt, mischt er eher relativ viele Dinge. Natürlich mein ich, dass auch einen sich selbst vermarkten, da Künstler, wenn er jetzt nicht wirklich gerade davon leben kann, dass er alles unter CC-Lizenz raushaut und trotzdem genug Spenden oder Einnahmen von Konzerten hat, da müssen wir uns nichts vormachen, das sind eher wenige, sollte natürlich auch irgendwie unglücklich sein oder ist im Zweifelsfall unglücklich, wenn seine Musik raubkopiert wird. Das hat jetzt erstmal nicht unbedingt was damit zu tun, dass man vielleicht keine Lust mehr auf Plattenfirmen hat, weil die Künstler ohnehin ein bisschen kurz halten. Viel wurde da vermischt und es gab mal wieder eine spannende Urheberrechtsdebatte mit ganz, ganz vielen Blogposts, die auf Sven Regener reagiert haben. Hauptsächlich, ich bin aber so enttäuscht, weil ich den Sven Regener so cool fand und jetzt ist er auf einmal fürs Urheberrecht. Ich fand es relativ ermüdend, weil es einerseits nicht besonders qualifiziert war, was er da gesagt hat, weil er leider viel gemischt hat, was die Argumentation, wenn er schon so einen Aufschlag macht und da irgendwie viele Dinge mischt, dann ist das ein bisschen traurig. Dann nimmt die Diskussion von da an in der Regel keinen sehr viel besseren Verlauf.
Ich hab auch so den Eindruck, dass man in der öffentlichen Debatte, wo wir jetzt gerade so beim Vermischen sind, das Urheberrecht, denke ich, steht eigentlich nur an der Stelle wirklich am Pranger, wo es um die Gültigkeitsdauer geht. Ein Recht, was 70 Jahre nach meinem Tod noch anderen Leuten, die nicht der Urheber sind, auf dieses Recht quasi zugesteht, halte ich für schwierig. Und zwar erst mal prinzipiell, weil es sozusagen etwas ist, was mich überlebt. Gut, jetzt kann man natürlich auch sagen, damit die Stars nicht alle gleich ermordet werden, wenn absehbar ist, dass sie eh nichts mehr Neues produzieren, ist es vielleicht auch ganz sinnvoll, da noch so eine Karenzzeit einzuführen. Da kann man ja glatt noch drüber diskutieren, aber so rein jetzt von der Logik her, warum soll mein Werk mich überdauern? Also warum soll vor allem das selbe Schutzrecht mich überdauern? Es ist ja schön, wenn mein Werk mich überdauert, aber was ist jetzt der Anspruch anderer, die diese Urheberschaft gar nicht geleistet haben? Also Erben vor allem, aber eben dann auch Leute, die vielleicht diese Rechte weitgehend aufkaufen, wo ist da der Sinn? Ich glaube, das ist das, wo die Leute eigentlich das Urheberrecht anprangern. Ansonsten steht mit Plattenfirmen, Labels und anderen, Middleman, eigentlich sehr viel mehr diese Verwertungsrechte.
Warte mal, ganz kurz, hier ist gerade ein störendes Hintergrundgeräusch.
Sie kommen. Alarm, brennt's schon?
Nee, das war der Wecker von gestern.
Also meiner Meinung nach stehen hier vor allem die Verwertungsrechte in der Hauptkritik. Das ist glaube ich das, woran sich die meisten Leute stören, weil das ganze Gebaren, dieses Anprangern von Raubkopien etc. diese gnadenlose legale Verfolgung von jedem, der irgendwie das Internet so benutzt, wie es sich nun mal eben einfach offenbart. Das geht ja gar nicht so sehr von den Urhebern aus. Das geht eher von denen aus, die eben von diesen Urhebern die Verwertungsrecht übernommen haben. Nicht erst wegen des Verwertungsrechts, aber weil natürlich deren Businessmodell im Wesentlichen da gefährdet ist. Und nicht unbedingt so sehr das Businessmodell der Urheber. Das, was manche Künstler so sehen. Das hier auch. Und das ist das, was ich jetzt hier so ein bisschen raushöre bei ihm. Bisher war es halt immer so und das soll jetzt nicht mehr gelten. Und der Künstler ist der Benachteiligte. Also als ob quasi die Konsequenz einer Änderung zwangsläufig bedeuten würde, dass Künstler da das nachsehen hätten. Was man allerdings glaube ich in der ganzen politischen Debatte einfach auch mal ein bisschen besser berücksichtigen muss, und das drückt sich hier auch ganz gut aus. Egal wie das jetzt von den tatsächlichen Forderungen her ist oder nicht, offensichtlich hat man die Künstler noch nicht erreicht. Offensichtlich läuft die ganze Debatte auf einem Level, wo noch wenig bis kein Verständnis da ist, insbesondere bei den etablierten Künstlern, aber sicherlich auch nicht nur dort. Ich kenne doch aus meinem eigenen Umfeld, was ein bisschen mehr von DJ-Kultur geprägt ist, etc., schon immer auch genau dieselbe Zurückhaltung, die immer wieder die Frage stellen, was soll denn mein Business-Modell sein? Und wenn man dann mit Konzerten kommt bei DJs, okay, DJs werden sowieso dadurch groß und haben dann später überhaupt erst mal die Möglichkeit mit Aufnahmen, mit selbst produzierter Musik später quasi als Musiker auch wirklich substanziell Geld zu verdienen. Es ist nicht so, dass jetzt ein DJ durch seine Auftritte besonders reich wird. Da gibt es natürlich auch Ausnahmen, aber es sind eben wirklich die Ausnahmen. Also was ich sagen will ist, ich vermisse oder ich sehe manchmal eine Schärfe in der Debatte, die sich zu pauschal gegen alles richtet, was da draußen ist und es wird einfach zu wenig differenziert und diese Debatte erfordert einfach mehr Differenzierung.
Also da stimme ich absolut mit dir über ein. Also insbesondere, was du gerade sagst, die Künstler haben das nachsehen. Die werden natürlich auch so ein bisschen zum Spielball gemacht und ich glaube, das war auch die herbe Enttäuschung oder warum jetzt gerade Sven Regener so viel Kritik und Helme und was nicht alles da entgegengeflogen ist, weil er wäre jetzt eigentlich einfach mal jemand gewesen, der hätte sagen können, hier Element of Crime, ab jetzt können uns die Labels gerne haben, wir machen unseren Kram selber und übrigens hier ist das Spendenkonto und wir verwerten irgendwie sekundäre Kanäle, Merchandise und so weiter jetzt auch alles selber und wollen einfach einen direkteren Kontakt zu den Fans haben. Das ist ja eigentlich, dass wenn man irgendwie die neue Kultur, die man jetzt irgendwie da sich heraufbeschwören sieht oder sich zusammenbrauen sieht, irgendwie mit einem Wort charakterisieren kann, das ist einfach mehr Nähe zwischen dem Schaffenden und den Konsumenten. Ja, ein direkteres Verhältnis zwischen beiden Parteien und das ist ja was ganz Tolles. Wenn man jetzt irgendwie, wenn er sagt, okay, die Indie-Labels gehen platt, es gibt deswegen weniger Musikvielfalt, das ist halt was, was, was Theorie, die er nicht wirklich halten kann. Weil es gibt, denke ich, genauso viel wie vorher, beziehungsweise sogar mehr und Musik-Labels waren jetzt mit dem, was sie auf Heavy Rotation geworfen haben, nun wirklich keine treibenden Kräfte hinter Abwechslungsreichtum in der Musikkultur. Und dann fällt mir aber noch ganz kurz ein, weil er hat dann natürlich Schützenhilfe bekommen von BMG, Bärlsmann Group, die sagen, ja gut, dass der Herr Regener da mal gesprochen hat und diese kostenlose Kultur, die müssen wir jetzt endlich mal abschaffen. Richten sich dann gegen kostenlose Kultur. Keiner fordert ernsthaft wirklich eine kostenlose Kultur. Also jedem ist ja irgendwie klar, dass da Leute auch unterstützt werden müssen. Dann gibt eben der Hartweg-Maasuch von BMG zu Protokoll, dass viele Kreative nur noch ein Monatseinkommen von 1.000 bis 2.000 Euro hätten, obwohl sie über Jahre hinweg große Hits hatten. Also, Entschuldigung, bei dem Satz muss man dann wirklich mal sagen, ja, herrje. Also ich meine, wenn der einen großen Hit hat, dann muss er halt den nächsten schreiben. Also der Anspruch, irgendwie von einem Hit dann ein Leben lang sich da... Von dem wird man sich dann doch wahrscheinlich trennen müssen. Und gleichzeitig, wenn, muss ich mal sagen, 1.000 bis 2.000 Euro, ich denke mal, das ist dann netto, wenn ich mir das vorstelle, weil ich über Jahre hinweg große Hits hatte, kriege ich immer noch ein Grundeinkommen von 2.000 Euro und muss dafür nichts weiter tun. Das heißt, ich habe da wirklich ein Longtail, von dem ich leben kann. Dann sehe ich das jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht als besonders kritischen Zustand. Dafür hat er, ich meine, 2.000 Euro kann man sich eigentlich ganz gut mit über Wasser halten und sich überlegen, was man als nächstes für einen Hit schreibt.
Ja, ich meine, für so einen BMG, was ist seine Rolle da? Vorstand? Ja, das ist natürlich eher Peanuts. Daher gilt das da wahrscheinlich schon eher als prekär. Ja, das ist halt auch so die grundsätzliche Frage, inwieweit es halt auch so ein Anrecht auf Business Modell gibt.
Also ich bin ja im Ruhrgebiet geboren. Und wenn man da mal den Leuten erklären würde, wenn ich jetzt mal so einem Arbeiter erklären würde, dass der sich einfach mal ein paar Jahre irgendwie gut gehen lassen soll bei 2000 Euro netto im Monat, weil er hat ja eine tolle Turbine gebaut. Der wird mir auch was an, also der wird ja auch lachen. Man muss sich natürlich schon irgendwie, es ist ganz klar, dass irgendwie materielle Arbeit und kulturschaffende Arbeit da in solcher Form nicht aufgewogen werden kann. Aber ich denke, dass wahrscheinlich solche Phänomene, wie irgendwie Multimillionäre im Musikbereich, man sich von der Vorstellung vielleicht in der Tat ein bisschen verabschieden muss. Wobei ich denke, dass das ohnehin irgendwie eher so ein Luftschloss war. Weil die Einzigen, die im Musikbereich Multimillionäre geworden sind, sind am Ende dann doch die Musiklabels gewesen. Und einige, sehr wenige Paradebeispiele in Deutschland wären das dann wahrscheinlich Westernhagen, Lindenberg, Grönemeyer, in den USA Madonna, Michael Jackson, sonst was, wo es dann irgendwelche Superstars gab, die wirklich ausgesorgt hatten. Aber ansonsten denke ich, wird auch der Musiker sich damit anfreunden müssen, dass er ein bisschen Druck bekommt, weiter zu produzieren und nicht nur Hotelzimmer zu zerlegen.
Also was man auf jeden Fall sieht, ist, dass die Leute, die jetzt versuchen, in diesem Bereich Urheberrecht, etc., Dinge vorantreiben zu wollen, dass sie sich auf jeden Fall mehr mit Künstlern auseinandersetzen müssen. Manche tun das sicherlich, da mag es aber auch sehr viele unterschiedliche Branchen geben, etc. und dann könnte diese Debatte dann auch ein bisschen weniger aufgeregt geführt werden.
Ja, das war eigentlich das Hauptthema heute. Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt es jetzt bald ab dem 1. April. Hatten wir ja schon gehört, tritt sie jetzt in Österreich in Kraft, nachdem die EU-Kommission da schon mit Strafzahlungen gedroht hatte. Dann gab es die nochmal kurz in den Medien wegen des Attentäters von Toulouse, weil da irgendwie mithilfe von Vorratsdaten fest irgendwie 576 Personen identifiziert wurden, die irgendwie eine Webseite besucht hatten. Und darunter befand sich dann auch die Mutter dieses Attentäters. Und das wurde natürlich dann sofort international dargestellt als ein Erfolg der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und Sarkozy sprechte dann auch sofort vor und sagte, er will jetzt irgendwie den Besuch extremistischer Websites bestrafen. Das heißt also, wir sehen da, was in Frankreich, haben wir also wirklich inzwischen wahrscheinlich jeden Kontakt verloren zu irgendwelchen rationalen Überlegungen. Und in Schweden hat man sich nach langem Hin und Her jetzt auch gerade zur Einführung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung entschieden, nachdem man bei einer Klage vor dem Europäischen Gerichtshof unterlegen ist. Also die Kommission strengt dann ein Verfahren vor dem Europäischen Gerichtshof gegen das Mitgliedsland an, was irgendwie sich nicht verhält, wie es soll. Und dann wird dann Urteil gesprochen. Im Falle von Schweden war das so, dass Schweden die Verfahrenskosten tragen musste, aber keine Strafzahlung bekommen hat. Also eigentlich relativ glimpflich, ein paar Euro gezahlt. Es hat gereicht, um das interne Landesinterne Parlament davon zu überzeugen, jetzt doch mal die Vorratsdatenspeicherung einzuführen. In Deutschland ist der Stand ja gerade, dass wir also am 2. März nach wie vor die Vorratsdatenspeicherung durch das Bundesverfassungsgericht gekippt haben. Und auf EU-Ebene hat die Kommission jetzt schon eine Überarbeitung vor über einem Jahr, eine Überarbeitung der Richtlinie angekündigt. Und möchte dafür irgendwie eine Evaluationsphase abwarten. Und hat aber an Deutschland auch schon zwei Mahnungen geschrieben, dass jetzt mal langsam irgendwie zugesehen werden muss, dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung wieder eingeführt wird. Und jetzt schrieb also Cecilia Malmström, die verantwortliche EU-Kommissarin, am 3. Februar einen Brief an die Bundesregierung oder an den Bundesinnenminister und sagte, ja, wir hätten jetzt mal ganz gerne ein bisschen Zahlen zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung, um mal quasi sie zu evaluieren. Wir wollen mal sehen, wie besser es bei euch geworden ist, damit wir diese Zahlen bei der Überarbeitung der Richtlinie berücksichtigen können. Klar, da geht's natürlich. Was also Evolution heißt ja eigentlich nur, sie wollen, sag ich mal, den Fahndungserfolg, sie wollen irgendwie Zahlen für Fahndungserfolg haben und die dann mit einer Grundrechtseinschränkung aufwiegen, um am Ende zu einer positiven Bilanz zu kommen. Das ist ja so ungefähr das, in welche Richtung die da arbeiten.
Kurze Anmerkung, dass wir Leute nicht verwirren, weil du meintest, hier Vorwärtsdatenspeicherung sei ja am 2. März gekippt worden. Das stimmt auch, aber halt nicht dieses Jahres.
Oh, 2010, ja.
Genau, so. Und die ganze Briefgeschichte, das ist jetzt aktuell dieses Jahr.
Ah, ja genau, wichtig zu sagen. Genau, diese Briefgeschichte ist jetzt hier im Februar und das kippen wir vor knapp zwei Jahren. Gleichzeitig hat der irische High Court irgendwie auch noch angekündigte, dass er vom EUGH die Vereinbarkeit der Vorwärtsdatensprechung mit den EU-Grundrechten geklärt haben will, aber da gibt es jetzt auch seit einiger Zeit nichts Neues. Also wichtiger Stand ist, Malmström schreibt 3. Februar an die Bundesregierung und sagt, gib doch mal Zahlen. Und dann kriegt sie am 28. Februar eine Antwort von Bundesinnenminister Friedrich. Die habe ich hier auch liegen. Und der sagt, ja, liebe Frau Kollegin, wir haben leider keine belastbaren Statistiken, aber wir haben erhebliche Einschränkungen, weil ja das Bundesverfassungsgericht uns da in die Parade gefahren ist und wir können hier keine Verbrechen mehr verfolgen. Und das BKA hat irgendwie mehrere Male hier horrende Zahlen. Die kriegen 85 Prozent der Fälle irgendwie nicht die Daten. Und in 80 Prozent der Fälle hat es dazu geführt, dass eine Straftat nicht oder nicht vollständig aufgeklärt beziehungsweise verhütet werden konnte. Das schreibt also unser Innenminister an die EU-Kommissarin Malmström. Den Studenten muss ich immer beibringen, dass eine Korrelation keine Kausalität ist. Nur weil etwas korreliert, heißt es nicht, dass es einen kausalen Zusammenhang gibt. Hier gibt es noch nicht einmal eine Korrelation. Wir haben ja nach wie vor keine Daten für den Fall, dass wir eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben. Das heißt, wenn er behauptet, in 80 Prozent der Fälle ist eine fehlende Vorratsdatenspeicherung dafür verantwortlich, dass eine Straftat nicht aufgeklärt oder verhütet werden konnte, dann ist das ganz einfach nur eine reine Spekulation. Also hätte er genauso gut irgendwie sagen können, wegen des Wetters oder...
Ja, oder wenn Zauberstab, wenn wir alle ausreichend mit Zauberstäben ausgerüstet wären, dann hätte er 25 Prozent bessere Aufklärungsquote.
Also solche Argumentationsmuster findest du eigentlich nur bei so religiösen Fanatikern, die dann alles immer mit ihr habt zu wenig gebetet erklären.
Ja, oder Homöopathen. Also ich meine, man könnte ja auch mal hier wirklich so den Placebo-Test machen. Also wenn Vorratsdatenspeicherung helfen würde, vielleicht hilft es halt auch, dass die Polizei lustige rote Hüte trägt.
Ja, also könnte man sagen, und dann könnte man genauso sagen, weil sie keine lustigen roten Hüte hatten, 80 Prozent nicht aufgeklebt. Nur selbst der Homöopath würde irgendwann mal versuchen, da so einen Vergleich herzustellen. Wobei, okay, stimmt, die wären sich da auch immer gegenklar. Aber so was schreibt also hochoffiziell unser Bundesinnenminister persönlich unterschrieben.
Mit der Homöopathie ist natürlich kein gutes Beispiel. Das würde wahrscheinlich im Wesentlichen bedeuten, dass man die Polizei weiter verdünnen müsste, damit sie wirkungsvoller wird.
Das wäre ja auch mal ein Ansatz. Wir reden ja jetzt eher hier bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Ich hoffe, dass sich mit diesem Vergleich jetzt niemand auf den Schlips trete. Aber das ist ja mehr so Chemotherapie gegen Schnupfen. Und zwar bei allen präventiv.
Ja, wobei vielleicht ist der Vergleich auch gar nicht so schlecht, ohne jetzt hier zu albern werden zu wollen. Aber im Prinzip ist ja so Vorratsdatenspeicherung auch so, wir brauchen mehr Heu, damit wir die Stecknadel finden. Das hat ja eigentlich auch schon so ein bisschen homöopathische Züge in gewisser Hinsicht.
Auf jeden Fall. Auf jeden Fall nach einem solchen Brief. Also wenn man sich das überlegt, da sitzt der EU-Kommissar und der Bundesinnenminister persönlich klar sein Leid, dass er keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat und bettelt ja quasi darum, dass die EU-Kommission jetzt einfach mal den Druck erhöht. Und das hat sie dann auch sofort gemacht. 22. März, wieder einen knappen Monat später, drei Wochen ungefähr, ist da so die Latenz in der Kommunikation der beiden. Setzt die Kommission eine Frist zur Umsetzung der Richtlinie von vier Wochen und droht sonst mit der bekannten europäischen Gerichtshofsklage, wo dann eben die Möglichkeit bestünde, dass man zu einer Strafzahlung verdonnert wird. Und sagt, man behindert den Binnenmarkt in der Telekom-Branche und die Möglichkeiten von Polizei und Justiz. Und jetzt muss endlich mal was geschehen. Den Binnenmarkt in der Telekom-Branche, ja. Also, meinen Sie wahrscheinlich die Europäische. Ich denke, dass sie den europäischen Binnenmarkt meint und sagt, dass ein deutscher Provider, weil er nicht Vorratsdatenspeicherung leisten muss, einen anderen europäischen Provider gegenüber Vorteile hat. Und das wollen wir ja in der EU nicht.
Das heißt, die geben auch zu, dass die finanzielle Belastung signifikant ist?
Genau. Und jetzt haben wir also diese Situation, jetzt haben wir das Thema richtig schön an der Tagesordnung. Druck ist da. Wir haben es schon gesehen. Ich meine, Österreich hat auch schon gekuscht, weil Strafzahlungen angedroht wurden. Schweden, wie ich gerade erwähnt hatte, hat zwar in dieser besagten Klage unterlegen, hat aber dann gar keine Strafzahlung bekommen, hat aber dann trotzdem wiederum gekuscht. Ich finde es eigentlich unsäglich, dass sich da die EU-Kommission mit Strafzahlungen anschickt, bei uns ein Gesetz zu erzwingen oder erpressen, was als grundgesetzwidrig mit sofortiger Wirkung für nichtig erklärt wurde. Wie Sabine Leuthäuser-Schnarrenberger, die Bundesjustizministerin sagt, die kritisiert, die haben also offensichtlich Zeit, hier Warnbriefe zu versenden, aber sind in einem Jahr nicht die Überarbeitung der Richtlinie angegangen. Da scheint es auch eine sehr klare Prioritätensetzung zu geben. Die Situation in Deutschland ist, die Bundesjustizministerin sieht die Kommission in der Pflicht, mal überhaupt diese seit 1,5 Jahren versprochene Überarbeitung zu leisten. Gleichzeitig sagt ja die FDP bzw. größere Teile der FDP mit Sabine Leuthäuser-Schnarrenberger, sie wollen also dieses Quick Freeze haben, als Alternative zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Wie gesagt, bei Quick Freeze muss man sich vorstellen, da laufen die Daten so durch und werden relativ kurz nur gespeichert. Und dann werden sie automatisch gelöscht, es sei denn, es wird mit einer richterlichen Anforderung, das Einfrieren der Daten einer bestimmten Person gefordert. Man identifiziert dann irgendwie, was weiß ich, von mir aus die Mutter von diesem Toulouse-Artentäter da. Und dann sagt man, da wird jetzt eingefroren. Genau, und das kann nämlich dann dieses Einfrieren kann jetzt, können wirklich unbürokratisch Ermittlungsbehörden schnell anfordern, sagen, friere mal da ein. Und dann kann man den langsamen Weg gehen, dass dann irgendwie Staatsanwälte, Richter und so weiter sagen, okay, und jetzt wollen wir die Daten auch haben. Das heißt, da gibt es wirklich dann, soll ich mal, eine sehr viel geringere Speicherung, eine sehr viel geringere Vollüberwachung. Und gleichzeitig einen vernünftigen Richtervorbehalt beim Zugriff auf diese Daten. Das sind also so die Argumente für Quick Freeze. Da gab es schon im November 2010 einen ersten Vorschlag von der FDP. Den habe ich jetzt auch noch mal verlinkt. Das ist also...
Macht man nicht so den Eindruck, als ob die CDU da große Lust drauf hätte, sich auf so ein Kompromiss einzubringen?
Nein, da hat die CDU überhaupt gar keine Lust drauf. Die CDU und CSU möchten ganz klar die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und Merkel schießt jetzt auch so auf diese Linie der Kommission. Und erinnert das Bundesjustizministerium an die fachliche, wie europapolitische Verantwortung. Diese Debatte wird da jetzt wieder hochgekocht. Es ist wieder mal nicht zu erwarten, dass sie auf einem höheren Niveau der fachlichen Durchdringung geführt wird. Wenn ich mich da jetzt nicht täusche, haben wir ja auch als einzigen in der FDP den Herrn Rösler, der genau konkret quasi die andere Position, also die CDU-Position hat. Das heißt, Rösler hat die CDU-Position bei Vorratsdatenspeicherung? Nein, hat er nicht.
Das kann ich mir auch ehrlich gesagt kaum vorstellen, dass die FDP... Ich meine, was bitte hat die FDP derzeit überhaupt noch in der Hand? Also die Situation, keine Ahnung, ob unser Podcast auch in 500 Jahren nochmal gehört wird, aber man muss ja mal kurz dran erinnern, dass sich gerade diese Partei in einem Niedergang befindet, der epische Ausmaße anzunehmen scheint. Also ich bin nicht überrascht, wenn die FDP vielleicht nicht von der Landkarte verschwindet, aber sich in diesem Jahr so dermaßen in die Nullprozent-Bereiche hineinkämpft. Der Postingon hat ja so eine schöne Meldung, so Überraschung, FDP überspringt deutlich die Nullprozent-Hürde bei der letzten Wahl im Saarland. Und keiner rechnet, glaube ich, überhaupt noch damit, dass sie hochkommen. Das heißt, diese Koalition ist eine Koalition auf Abruf. Es wird wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht unbedingt zu vorzeitigen Neuwahlen kommen, es sei denn, passiert jetzt noch irgendein derzeit nicht absehbares Drama. Aber wenn sie jetzt noch irgendetwas haben, wo sie halbwegs Profil zeigen können, dann ist diese Position beizubehalten. Von daher glaube ich auch nicht, dass da im Bereich Vorratsdatenspeicherung in irgendeiner Form ein Kompromiss erzielt wird, der diese Regierung dann, also denen diese Regierung als solche überleben würde. Das wäre dann so ein Knackpunkt, an dem es dann nochmal komplett zerspringt. Das wäre jetzt für Sabine Leuthäuser-Schnarrenberger auch nichts Neues. Die ist ja schon mal aus ähnlichen Gründen zurückgetreten. Und bei einem Rücktritt von ihr kann sich die FDP als solche nicht erlauben. Zumal sie sich ja derzeit auch in der Auseinandersetzung mit der Piratenpartei da die ganze Zeit wieder in diese Illusion hineinschraubt, sie hätte noch irgendetwas mit freiheitlichen Werten zu tun. Das ist eigentlich nur noch in Form von Sabine Leuthäuser-Schnarrenberger, wenn es sie nicht gäbe, glaube ich, wäre der ganze liberale Inhalt der FDP gleich null.
Also für die Nachwelt nochmal, FDP, die Freie Demokratische Partei, die also, ich glaube, was haben sie sich hauptsächlich, die waren ja auch mal, ich meine, die waren ja durchaus mal tatsächlich irgendwie beliebt. Das Problem ist, dass sie, glaube ich, in letzten Jahren ihre Liberalidee ein bisschen sehr auf die Marktfreiheit gelegt haben und ihren Grundrechtskram da eher in Form der Personalien Leuthäuser-Schnarrenberger irgendwie haben durchschleifen lassen. Aber zu, glaube ich, zur allgemeinen Überraschung der Historiker ja auch gerade zu Zeiten der Finanzkrise ein Traumergebnis eingefahren haben.
Du meinst ein Bundestagswahl-Ergebnis.
Ja, aber das... Okay, brauchen wir jetzt nicht ins Detail zu gehen, aber da zeichnete sich ja auch schon, je nachdem, welche Finanzkrise man jetzt meint.
Das ist richtig, das wurde wahrscheinlich einfach in dem Moment noch nicht im Zusammenhang gesehen. Aber dann im Nachgang sehr wohl.
Also hauptsächlich, glaube ich, inzwischen unbeliebt für ihre sozialstaatsfeindlichen Positionen, Hotelsteuern und so, wie dem auch sei. Also diese Partei ist inzwischen irgendwie in Landtagswahlen bei unter anderthalb Prozent angelangt. Und das ist im Moment unsere Hoffnung in der Regierungskoalition, um eventuell dann noch irgendwie etwas Sinn und Verstand ins Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu bringen.
Ja, es ist wirklich eine völlig absurde Situation eigentlich. Dass das der einzige Allianzpartner eigentlich jemand ist, dem man eigentlich so überhaupt nichts mehr zutraut. So, haben wir denn die VDS-News beisammen?
Ja, also nur nochmal, ich hab da eine größere Linksammlung. Viele dieser Links gehen zu den Seiten des AK-Vorrats, wo dann eben auch gesagt wird, ja, dieser Druck mit den Strafzahlungen und so, wo das wirklich dann auch mal relativiert wird. Ich hab mich ja jetzt auch bemüht, das hier mit anzusprechen. Das lasst sie da mal mit ihren Strafzahlungen kommen. Also das wär jetzt eigentlich, sag ich mal, eine Haltung, die man da einnehmen könnte. Aber sieht erstmal nicht so aus, als würde die Bundesregierung das machen. Ich mein, in Form des Bundesinnenministers haben die sicher diesen Strafbrief selber bestellt. Und das finde ich, also da muss ich echt sein, das finde ich schon ein Skandal eigentlich. Also dass der Innenminister irgendwie sich das Schützenhilfe von der EU holt und sagt, droht uns mal hier mit einer Klage und macht mal eine ordentliche Deadline. Und das alles bei einer Richtlinie, die relativ offensichtlich, wie auch schon geurteilt, irgendwie unserer Verfassung widerspricht. Da, sag ich mal, hört dann mein Verständnis und Humor in solchen Angelegenheiten schon auf. Nächste Thema. EU will endlich mal das Haken verbieten.
Das wurde ja auch mal Zeit, das nimmt echt überhand.
Echt, das nimmt überhand. Die hacken da rum und irgendwie geht nicht mehr. Und da hatten wir jetzt gerade die Bekanntmachung, die ist erst gestern reingekommen, dass jetzt also das Haken von IT-Systemen eine kriminelle Maßnahme werden soll oder eine kriminelle Handlung werden soll. Und natürlich auch, wir kennen das von Deutschland, vom Hacker-Paragrafen, dass das Verteilen und Besitzen von Software und Tools strafbar werden soll, die sich dazu eignen zu hacken. Da muss man sich natürlich vorstellen, dass gerade diese Software und Tools ganz besonders in der IT-Sicherheitsbranche benutzt werden, nämlich um zu prüfen, ob man gegen Angriffe resistent ist. Also ich hab irgendwie ein Computersystem und dann gibt's, sag ich mal, das Universum der möglichen Angriffe. Und dafür gibt's natürlich in der Regel Tools, die ich dann nutze oder sogar ganz große Toolsammlungen, die eine Reihe von Angriffen gegen meine Infrastruktur fahren, damit ich prüfen kann, dass kein Krimineller da reinkommt mit einfachen Hausmitteln.
In dem Bericht, auf den wir uns beziehen, berichtet dann Berichterstatterin ist Monika Hohlmeier, also known as die Tochter von Franz Josef Strauß, die hier von ein paar Jahren mal im Rahmen eines kleineren Poliz-Gandälchens dann nach Europa strafversetzt wurde und jetzt dort mit interessanten Vergleichen wieder einmal, wie wir sie besonders lieben. Nach dem Motto, was in der realen Welt nicht sein darf, das darf ja im Internet schon gar nicht sein. In diesem Fall meint sie, die Sicherheitsszenerie dadurch gut vergleichen zu können, dass sie sagt, wenn ein Autohersteller keine Sicherheitsgurte mit ausrüstet, das ginge ja schon gar nicht. Und wenn es dann doch noch passiert, dann müsste man natürlich auch diese Firma dafür verantwortlich machen können. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie häufig das jetzt schon so passiert ist, dass Mercedes mal Autos ohne Sicherheitsgurte ausgeliefert hat. Davon mal ganz abgesehen.
Wie ist die Analogie, wenn sie sagt, ihr Auto kommt ohne Sicherheitsgurte und deswegen verbieten wir...
Ich bin auch noch ein bisschen am Gröbeln. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt generell mit solchen Analogien daherkommen möchte, dann könnte man natürlich auch sagen, Schlüsseldienste dürften keine Werkzeuge haben, mit denen man Türen öffnen kann.
Ja, das ist ja auch, das ist ja genau das.
Ja, weil wo kommen wir denn dann hin? Weil dann wäre es ja möglich, jede Tür zu öffnen. Oder so. Keine Ahnung. Also das macht irgendwie alles so recht keinen Sinn. Der Kampf gegen Hacker-Tools wird ja schon etwas länger geführt. In Deutschland gibt es meines Wissens eigentlich noch eine gültige Regelung, die im Prinzip ja auch schon so einen Unsinn unter Strafe, also die auch schon so eine unsinnige Gesetzgebung hat. Ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht mehr ganz so sicher. Es hat sich ja mal jemand selber angezeigt. Erinnerst du dich an diese Geschichte?
Vage.
Vage, ich weiß jetzt nämlich auch nicht mehr, wie es ausgegangen ist.
Nee, doch, ich erinnere mich. Ich tue jetzt einfach mal so, als würde ich mich erinnern. Ich habe die Wikipedia-Seite auf. Das war der Michael Kubat. Der hatte sich selbst angezeigt. Und irgendwie dann im Februar 2008 wurde das von der Staatsanwaltschaft Mannheim eingestellt. Und in einem ähnlichen Fall hatte jemand Strafanzeige gegen das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik gestellt. Das war mir nicht bekannt. Also es gab einmal die Selbstanzeige von Michael Kubat, die wurde im Februar 2008 eingestellt. Und irgendjemand hat dann das BSI angezeigt, weil das Amt gegen das Gesetz verstoße. Und das hat dann die Staatsanwaltschaft Bonn das Ermittlungsverfahren schon eingestellt. Da gab es also gar keine...
Ja, es ist unglaublich. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, ich lese gerade in der Principia Discordia. Polizisten sind gefährlich, denn sie tragen Waffen. Das ist schon etwas absurd. Nichtsdestotrotz gibt es jetzt wieder eine neue Maßnahme. Das ist jetzt alles noch sehr neu und sehr jung. Viele andere Regelungen, die hier angesprochen werden, wenden sich eigentlich grundsätzlich gegen Sachen wie IP-Spoofing etc. Im weiteren Sinne wird auch Firmen, die jetzt selber hacken lassen, dann quasi auch eine entsprechende Haftung nachgestellt. Das sind jetzt nicht generell verachtenswürdige Maßnahmen. Selbstverständlich sollten Betreiber von Botnetzen, Betreiber von gezielten, ich will jetzt nicht Cyberattacken sagen, aber elektronischen Maßnahmen im Netz, die die Integrität anderer Systeme gefährden, natürlich ist das beurteilungswürdig und es sollten auch entsprechende Maßnahmen dagegen ergriffen werden. Wo es aber wirklich mal wieder schwierig ist, ist einfach dieser Bereich der Hacker-Werkzeuge, weil die machen uns richtig Arbeit.
Auch zu dem ersten, was du jetzt gerade sagst, es wäre mir neu, dass das legal ist. Es wäre mir erstens neu, dass das Betreiben von Botnetzen und Infizieren von Rechnern neuerdings legal wäre. Und zweitens wäre es mir auch neu, dass solche Angriffe aus Bereichen stattfinden, wo Europa großartige Jurisdiktion hat.
Ja, hier steht ja auch This would update existing EU legislation on cyberattacks. Also es ist schon als weitergehende Maßnahme gedacht. Ich denke, wir müssen uns mal vielleicht für die nächste Woche nochmal den Ist-Zustand genauer anschauen und schauen, was hier wirklich jetzt neu wäre, bevor wir jetzt auch zu sehr frei drehen. Auf jeden Fall ist das hier gerade in Spotlight gekommen.
Genau, aktueller Stand wurde also abgestimmt im Civil Liberties Committee, gerade am Dienstag. Und 50 zu eine Stimme bei drei Enthaltungen. Also da sieht nach etwas aus, was einen relativ einfachen Lauf haben wird. Und Strafenmaße, die da so angesehen werden, ist irgendwie zwischen zwei und fünf Jahren, wobei man bei fünf Jahren dann bei so einem Bordnetz wäre. Dann kam für mich so auf einem Ohr die Meldung rein. Die gebe ich jetzt echt einfach nur ganz kurz so weiter, dass ACTA nun doch im EU-Parlament abgestimmt werden soll, ohne auf das Ergebnis der EUGH-Entscheidung zu warten. Meine erste Reaktion darauf war zu sagen, was, jetzt pressen sie es doch durch. Andererseits wird von einigen argumentiert, dass man darauf hofft, dass nach dieser großen Protestwelle quasi jetzt auch so das Parlament einfach schon dagegen stimmt, ohne dass man in irgendeinem EUGH-Verfahren da juristische Haarspalterei betreibt, um das Ding irgendwie verfassungskonform zu machen. Was ja ähnliches ist, was im Falle von der Vorratsansprechung eben gerade in Deutschland stattfindet. Dass irgendwie ein Verfassungsgericht geurteilt hat, das und das und das geht nicht. Und dass dann sofort eigentlich sich angestrengt wird, etwas zu schaffen, was genau diese Grenzen dann einhält. Insofern eventuell doch dann schon eine Abstimmung im EU-Parlament dieses Jahr. Und hoffentlich dann eine Ablehnung. Und zwar eine ganzheitliche Ablehnung statt irgendwelcher Detaildebatten. Und eine weitere Kurzmeldung beträfe dann das, wieder EU, meine Güte, Logbuch EU. Und da geht es um das Fluggastdatenabkommen, über das wir letzte Woche auch schon mit Thomas Lohninger gesprochen hatten. Das hatte jetzt seine Abstimmung im Innenausschuss des EU-Parlaments. Und da wurde mit 31 zu 23 Stimmen dafür gestimmt, in diesem Innenausschuss. Und auch da ist wieder dann der nächste Schritt. Es geht dann jetzt ins große Plenum. Und da kann man also auch bei den von uns schon gegebenen Links, die wiederhole ich dann nochmal eben jetzt, seine Abgeordneten kontaktieren. Und da geht es also um das Übertragen von Fluggastdaten in die USA betrifft. Also erstmal eine USA-Reisende, aber wie wir letztes Mal schon geklärt hatten, ist das der Aufschlag dafür, so was Ähnliches EU-intern dann auch durchzusetzen.
Also vielleicht zum Allgemeinen Parlamentsverständnis normal. Der Innenausschuss hat erst mal gar nichts zu beschließen, aber die haben zumindest beschlossen, dass sie das gut finden und das muss letzten Endes aber durchs Parlament.
Genau. Ansonsten fällt mir glaube ich noch, vielleicht bei diesem PNR gibt es ja dieses Tool von Digitale Gesellschaft, wo die Abgeordneten mit ihren öffentlich bekannten Positionen dargestellt werden. Wo dann steht hier irgendwie dafür, dagegen oder unbekannt Wackelkandidat. Da hatte sich jetzt der Reinhard Büttikover sehr darüber aufgeregt, weil er wohl auf den Seiten, der auf dieser Seite der digitalen Gesellschaft irgendwie als Wackelkandidat unbekannt stand. Und dann hatte er sich schon beschwert, dann wurde das geändert und seine Position wurde richtig eingeordnet. Dann hat er eine Woche gewartet und twitterte, digitale Gesellschaft wären verleumdarische Arschlöcher, weil sie Korrektur korrigieren würden. Scheint aber so zu sein, dass er einfach nur seinen Browser-Cache nicht aktualisiert hatte. Es war geändert. Dann gibt es also ein relativ langes Statement auf den Seiten von digitaler Gesellschaft, wo man sich einfach mal fragt, wie reagiert man eben wieder darauf. Dass irgendwie ein Verfahren gewählt wird oder ein Verfahren implementiert wird, was so ein bisschen Transparenz in Abstimmungsverhalten geben soll, was den Menschen die Möglichkeit bieten soll, auf ihre Abgeordneten einzuwirken. Und dann kommt da die große Welle des Fluches, was einem einfällt, Politiker zu verleumden und an den Pranger zu stellen mit ihren Entscheidungen. Ein ganz interessanter Vorgang für Menschen, die sich vielleicht ein bisschen mehr für mehr Demokratie interessieren in solchen Fällen.
Was ist denn jetzt seine Position?
Er ist wohl dagegen. Er wollte das also dann klar so haben. Da war dann irgendwie großes Hin und Her. Ich fand es eher die Reaktion der Politiker auf diese Darstellung einer Abstimmungsverhaltensprognose. Wir kennen es ja schon aus vielen Fällen von Abgeordneten. Ein Watch, wo dann vergangenes Verhalten protokolliert wird und den Leuten Fragen gestellt werden können. Und da gibt es ja dann auch immer wieder irgendeinen Landrat oder irgendwelche Gruppen, die dann irgendwie meinen, sie müssten da jetzt gegen klagen und sich irgendwie gegen diese Anstrengung, Transparenz einfach nur diesen Prozess zu dokumentieren. Und letztendlich vielleicht von Seiten der Zivilgesellschaft diese Distanz zwischen politischen Entscheidungsträgern und Gesellschaft zu verkleinern. Also ein Schritt auf sie zu, könnte man ja sagen. Denen wird eben auch immer mit großer Skepsis und mit rechtlichen Schritten entgegengewirkt. Und deswegen fand ich es jetzt immer ganz interessant bei diesem PNR-Tool, was da bei Digitale Gesellschaft zum Eingangs kommt.
Ja, dann haben wir es was.
Ja, das war es für heute.
Heute mal eine etwas improvisiertere Geschichte durch Ferne, aber immerhin, wir bleiben uns treu und bringen hier jede Woche die Aktualität. Das schaffen wir nächste Woche auch. Müssen wir uns nochmal über einen Termin unterhalten, sehe ich gerade. Aber das braucht die Hörer ja nicht zu interessieren. Für euch ist nur interessant, dass sich hier alles abonnieren lässt und an der Stelle würde ich mich auch gerne nochmal bedanken für die hier neu gewonnene Treue zu diesem Format. Wir sehen nach wie vor steigende Abrufzahlen und das freut uns natürlich sehr. Auch die Unterstützung über Fletter und andere Wege. Immer mal wieder gibt es auch Hinweise auf Themen auf Twitter und anderen Kanälen. Das könnt ihr auch gerne weiterhin so halten, denn auch wir sehen vielleicht nicht unbedingt immer alles und wollen ja hier das Interessante der Aktivitäten der letzten Woche zusammenfassen.
Ja und um Sven Regener da dann doch nochmal anzustrengen, der Fletter-Button ist existent. Ich kann mich da auch überhaupt nicht über dessen Verwendung beschweren. Das war jetzt, ich bin jetzt endlich in der Riege jener, die es einmal geschafft haben, an einem Podcast beteiligt zu sein, der über 100 Fletter erreicht hat.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das so ein, ist das so eine Hürde, so eine allgemeine Anerkennung?
Also ich hab mir jetzt diesen Fletter-Button mit den über 100 einfach mal als Button machen lassen, Mal gucken, dass du nicht bald aussiehst wie so ein russischer General, weil ich sehe die Sendung davor, die ist auch schon bei 100 und die da vor 98, da kann er einiges zusammenkommen. Also freut mich auf jeden Fall, dass das Format so einen Anklang findet und lasst das da nicht abklingen, um das mit Sven Regen das Worten zu sagen, wenn ihr das einfach nehmt und sagt, das ist nichts wert, dann pinkelt ihr uns ins Gesicht. Bis nächste Woche. Tschüss.